[Music]
[Applause]
what would be the one word you would use
to describe your dance style
what's your name dude your wallet is
chained to your pants
[Applause]
[Music]
and what would you say is the name
of your best dancer
now you pointed to your friends she seen
the psychopath before
oh
yo i can't [__] wait to see
[Applause]
[Music]
wanna
[Applause]
i think this this actually works for you
i
[Music]
[Applause]
more
[Music]
[Applause]
i think you showed a nipple you might
win
[Music]
i don't want to tip your hand but i
think maybe it may be a meanie nipple
might get you a big w on this one
did the other eye come out too
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
i got two
pure words
[__] sex salesman i'm not gonna lie to
you you had smaller areolas than i
thought you did
yeah no i have bigger aerials than i
should
[Music]
that was
awesome
and since it was solved
i think both of you are just going to
win
[Applause]
[Music]
but you know how the story goes another
drink another dollar howler 7 pm once
i'm gonna break another bug